[Music]
well it's great to see you again I said
it's fun because we've known each other
a while and like through the years the
years will pass and we'll keep bumping
into each other yes and all the amazing
things that you've been doing through
the years you're also you knew me before
all that all that there was no
housewives it was just me and a baby and
your wife and a baby at my house that I
know I know I mean it was like they were
so tiny now they're so big
imagine six foot two yes so let me let's
start there okay what was his reaction
when you told them that you're gonna be
doing Celebrity Big Brother like they
were like oh yeah they said just don't
come home unless you win and eat a bug
if you have to I'm like what that's the
advice listen that's the advice you get
from kids yeah you gotta win yeah and
you gotta do chicken what do we get if
you win what's in a frog right basically
hurts
no let's back up a little bit are you
fan of the show how did it come your way
uh you know what this is really funny I
got a call a few days ago so I'm
replacing someone um and so they said
are you available on Sunday and it was
like Wednesday and I just said yeah and
so I'm here well you know thank goodness
you used to be in like on the go on the
fly okay you're used to cameras around
you I mean basically from the you know
obviously yes do you think that gives
you some level an advantage I mean
you're used to playing to the cameras
and being aware of them yeah I think
that it might put a target on me okay
because you know like I am the reality
kind of all-star I've been this is what
I do I'm not a singer and actor Natalie
so I think people might think I have
like you know an upper hand in a way
which I don't because I wish I was an
actor and you know I wish I could lie
and backstab and do all that fun stuff
but um yeah I feel like people might
want me out because of that or because
of a lot of other reasons um but I'm
excited that sorry I asked if you're
faced with we had you been watching the
show in the pasture
I've not watched the United States
version I've actually participated by
the UK right
I forgot about that I'm getting all my
cards mixed up you participated so and
not only that you're so familiar the
cameras I mean that's got it that of all
things might put a little target on your
back how are you gonna play how you
gonna strategize about you know me I
don't have strategy you know I'm just
gonna kind of free ball it like you'd
like you do like they called me on
Wednesday I'm here on Sunday like listen
let's do it I know you a little bit like
I think I know the answer this question
but what are you most nervous about what
are you worried about as far as I mean
for me what comes up is one of about the
kids like am I gonna do something that
would be riots well I think I pretty
much already done all of that so and my
kids think I know epic and awesome they
think I'm pretty badass I'm not gonna
lie um which is great I have boys so you
know boys I don't know I beat them at
handle I don't let the one of video
games I don't want them one of anything
and so they think I'm like a superhero
in some way so I have to win somehow I
mean how are you gonna win well I don't
know yet I just started watching the the
US version last night virgin version
version last night yeah and I'm a little
nervous for myself only because I have
my holiday body still I haven't been
working out and it seems like there's a
lot more physical activity and I'm not
20 well so well yeah well you know are
at yourself because you're still in
great shape but I know she made like a
fair to you range it is seems like
there's a bit more emphasis on physical
activity yeah yeah we just side around
like we're play charades it's a lot
different and then the public voted you
out it wasn't like this strategy
situation where it's like human chess so
it was pretty fun
but um I'm just a little worried about
like the physical part but I'm just
gonna try my best and I won't quit and
that's all I can do you will not let me
ask you this more drama on Real
Housewives or more drama in the Big
Brother celebrity house Oh Real
Housewives are you kidding
I mean we could like this celebrity
house we were fighting over like food
portions you know and on housewives are
fighting over Rosie and diamonds
but that's like pulling hair and be
crazy but in a way that also you I mean
you're comfortable with being under the
microscope and also having that drama
going on which likely will happen in the
house as well right so I mean that's
something you're not going to shy away
from or know I mean I wish I could
change when I mean everyone knows they
kind of get the reaction for me when
they go for it I'm working on changing
that but I only have a few days to work
on that so I'm hoping I can kind of be
calmer but I I mean listen you know how
old a man died it hasn't changed yet
so I don't foresee it changing but you
know we'll see listen I can't wait to
watch we'll say that coming back to one
thing that I don't think that you've had
to do before I separate when you're on
the UK version of course is you know
sort of signing off from the world no
cell phone no watch no idea how is that
for you it's amazing honestly I thought
the answer I thought I was great you
know I'm not but I'm not you don't I
have a girlfriend that does a lot of my
social media for me um I'm not that
person that needs to document every
single thing I do my phone gives me
anxiety so I have xanax at all times so
it's like 20,000 emails and everyone
wants an answer in a contract sign right
now and you have to decide you know it's
it's very freeing not to have it I
really enjoy I do miss music because I
love music so that's that's unfortunate
but hopefully it would be some singers
that I like will you have oh yeah my
doctor signed off on it I like of this
it may also be on Wednesday like here's
a list of my medications and they just
idea I think house you listen I I'm
pretty sure I'll have at least one panic
attack in there
what about by the way that's that's
artis that's what happened that's our DS
for this segment right there I think
that was fantastic
how about being your own personal glam
squad I mean honey I forgot to tell you
totally I do it anyway
really yes I'm not I'm not a fan not
like everyone thinks that
of housewives like Lisa Vanderpump like
going around PR and glam squad I'm not
that person I really am just a mom that
lives in my gym clothes half the time
and I I can't do hair I'm not gonna lie
so I had somebody did this but I can do
makeup and I don't really I can just I
kind of washed and wear with the hair
ponytail yeah sure if I kick I just suck
it doing here it's pretty much just what
it's I have one hairdo and it's a wave
that's all I can do I can do it like a
little wave
that's why I've had the same hairstyle
for a while huh some photos were
released with the house there's a few
changes I mean I know you just start to
get to you at the US version but you got
a square table you got an espresso
machine did you catch that I haven't
seen anything
Oh uh-oh I say this cuz they're released
right okay yeah you got you got espresso
that is amazing it's not a cool because
I have Nespresso the the at my house and
it's my bits my crack yeah I can't but I
need them Dirk black pods yeah I think
they're really strong stuff I'm very
excited and by the way your own bed not
sure bed oh okay
I sure do that my pain about giving you
father me because she was hot number one
and she was sweet and there was an
elderly woman that needed her own bed
and she didn't get it so I was just like
take it I'll share she wasn't that old
not just going oh my god she was just
she was not that old but she just needed
her own gun you just called her a little
bit like probably I don't even want to
guess that's your older so you said
you're you're low maintenance in a lot
of ways more low means than people like
think from watching housewives what
about food the food can be a little
tricky how did you and you keep it I
mean I mean is the food the same thing
they have better food cuz you get the
slop it could be I don't know I really
I'm not familiar with everything here
yet um the UK we have we were on rations
we were on like we had only lentils for
like a week okay people kept melting up
and I was one of the cooks which was
great until this other lady got really
pissed at me and tried to take the
kitchen over and then we had
kitchen Wars yeah I really like you
fight over the dumbest things because
there's nothing else to do so then I
started doing people's hair and makeup
for them because I need to have purpose
so yeah I have to do something for
someone not if you may not like sexually
but well that no no what about the show
mantis I mean that's been a part of the
seasons past is that impossible I don't
know are you uh I am NOT I'm recently
single okay so I mean I'm open for
anything that's natural I'm not gonna
like trying to have a showmance but
generally when you're in a house with
someone you end up having chemistry with
someone it's happened in the past so
yeah it can it's happened a couple times
there you go yeah well how is it hard
for you to be away from the kids for
this though you know I'm divorced as you
know so my ex-husband has them half the
time anyway so we a week on week off so
it's really I'm really missing only two
weeks of their life if I win I see for
the whole month and so and then he goes
off to a job for a month so I'll have
them for our straight months so it kind
of works out how did he react to any
react to you doing this well I couldn't
tell him what I was doing because I
don't trust him
yes I thought it was like you science it
I thought it was like a non-disclosure
but you could you because you don't know
because it was before they thought they
were announcing it on the gram reason
and they're like be careful because they
might leak it to the press so I just
thought I'm doing a show I might have to
travel for and be away and no contact I
didn't I lied a lot but I just I just
I'm I left out I left out things and so
I think you figured it out my Sunday but
by then it was getting announced so
there was no like they couldn't jack me
you